here are some of my favorite bugs people
have found in stockfield so far most of
them are funny but this one's actually
just kind of pretty this person's
missiles created their own orbit after a
fight this person has just had this rock
following them for like a hundred hours
now it even gatecrashed their wedding
and if you thought that was bad somehow
this person has the whole of like new
Atlantis
following them around
I've seen a few people have this now and
it is the funniest one yet
best employee ever 20 XP
Sarah just doing some sort of weird
plank these ones are like always my
favorites
um sir this is a Wendy's and of course
just a whole lot of this this is
actually the only bug that I have like
very consistently had and the secret is
I don't even mind it I think it's funny
enough that I prefer it be there than
not that's my hot take